le dernier ferme bien important sinon
les acteurs c'est charles une immersion
dans la nature à la rencontre du roi de
la forêt c'est grâce à l'oeil aguerri
d'ambroise graffin directeur de l'espace
rambouillet que les visiteurs vont
pouvoir approcher au plus près des
animaux cerfs chevreuils d'un et
sangliers se promène dans cet espace de
180 hectares mais pour être sûr d
écouter le brame
il faut d'abord trouver les biches j'ai
vu de mal ils ont fait le tour ils sont
revenus par là bas il y en a encore qui
sont là bas il en a tendance à se
regrouper à se rapprocher voire de biche
soit le au lever du soleil soit soit
crépuscule d'une couronne où la nuit
tombe mais les recherches se poursuivent
la harde de biche fini par se deviner
dans la pénombre et si on a du brame
c'est à cet endroit là qui va se
concentrer
le brame le fameux cri poussé par le ser
il sera pas pousse pousse et uniquement
par le cerf dominant la part du temps en
fait c'est un jeu d'intimidation entre
se sert de maintenant et quelques serres
qui sont autour
à 2,3 en général et qu'ils vont chercher
à lui piquer sa place
un cri qui marque aussi une volonté
d'accouplement mais ce soir les 25
animaux n'étaient pas très entreprenants
malgré plusieurs minutes d'attentes
ils sont restés silencieux à la
clairière ça nous a permis cette balade
de observer des animaux
dans une phase presque nocturne et qui
est un peu plus croustillantes
après il nous a manqué ce soir un petit
peu le son que le brame proprement dit
ça arrive il faut rester humble devant
la nature la période du brame s'étend
jusqu'à mi octobre avec un peu de chance
et beaucoup de patience encore quelques
jours pour en profiter